so um
big came to me in a dream last night
meaning you had a dream about big and
just like that hbo max's sex in the city
revival series wraps up the big love
story without chris noth as carrie
reconnects with samantha what's
wonderful is that we have a writer and
actors who love that character who love
telling stories and being in
situations and environments with
samantha
and we're really lucky we have those
memories and that experience
the season one finale kicks off with
carrie's third date with peter which
ends with a sweet but sort of cringy
first kiss
i'd like to kiss you
and that'd be okay
and all that really just has her
thinking about big whose ashes are still
stored in her closet
of course the series launched with an
unexpected bombshell
and just like that
they died and fans aren't too happy
about it i love that people are upset it
means they care i think it was very bold
we're not going to be treading water
we're actually going to be sailing into
completely unchartered waters and
shortly after that controversial episode
aired the show decided to remove
additional footage of chris noth's
character from the finale after several
women came forward accusing the 67 year
old actor of sexual assault we were
very lucky that those changes were
able to be made we just wanted people to
not be distracted so while big comes to
carry in a dream to reveal where he
wants his ashes dispersed fans never
actually see or hear him
so um
big came to me in a dream last night i
know where he wants to be
paris
our bridge
of course fans of the original show will
recall that in the final episode of the
series big found kerry in paris they
kissed on a bridge and seemingly lived
happily ever after
carrie you're the one
kiss me a big cry baby
so that's exactly where carrie goes to
say her final goodbye to big
[Music]
and since carrie's in paris just a hop
skip and a train ride away from london
she reaches out to her estranged pal
samantha to meet up for a cocktail and
get this sam agrees it's shocking it's
shocking this all comes after kim
cattrall who played samantha in the
original series made it clear she will
not return to the franchise it's a topic
e.t asked the actress about in 2014 four
years after the release of sex in the
city too the most important thing is
always do we have something left to say
how do i want to spend the time do i
want to spend it doing something that
i've explored to the fullest do i want
to come back and revisit it i think it's
about the story if there's something
more to say yes financially it would be
fantastic for all of us
but
i'm really about content and
what is it what is it where is it going
to take me so the show forged ahead
without her leaving the door open for a
possible return we did everything we
could to honor samantha who we love the
character and we know the fans love
no one could be another samantha i
personally feel
very pleased with how we've handled it
i think michael patrick
cares deeply about handling it with
respect and i feel that we have so could
samantha come back if the show gets
picked up for a season two when e.t
spoke to cynthia nixon she said fans
shouldn't hold their breath
i think that kim has made it really
clear that she's done and we've heard
her and sometimes people say you know
who will be the new cement but we would
never try to replace samantha
[Music]
you